[Musique]
soit
c'est dans cette petite case à
sainte-suzanne que vinet lydie jouer son
mari germain ce couple de retraités a
bénéficié de travaux d'amélioration de
leur habitat
et c'est avec beaucoup de fierté que
nady dijoux nous montre sa nouvelle
salle de bain donc là c'est votre salle
de bain qui était refaite
alors que si l'on fait comme travaux
chever voilà les hommages à ses côtés et
comme on l'a connu l'eau si le
dispositif est passé quand il était
l'ami du talent elle est passionnante
enquête ici vous moi comment comment
était la seule à dire que l'on était mal
ajouté les toilettes étaient pas beau le
salut ali ben bella de la fille de nous
fait la demande même l'avait fait et la
rue maginot qui paiera
[Musique]
pour bénéficier de l'aide il faut être
une personne âgée de 65 ans au plus ou
une personne handicapée ou encore une
famille en suroccupation les
accueillants familiaux également peuvent
bénéficier de cette aide dans le cadre
de leurs activités
par ailleurs il faut occuper son
logement à titre de résidence principale
être propriétaire occupant ou locataires
des logements du parc privé ou encore
occupants à titre gratuit
les travaux qui sont liées à
l'amélioration concerne l'hygiène la
sécurité
l'adaptabilité du logement l'adaptation
des sanitaires et enfin la création
d'une chambre pour les personnes en
circulation il faut retenir que les
revenus de l'ensemble des personnes
occupant le logement améliorées seront
prises en compte et ne devront pas
dépasser le plafond de ressources
exigées par le règlement départemental
pour plus d'informations sur ce
dispositif vous pouvez contacter les
arrondissements de la direction de la
ville
[Musique]
la star des bassins de corse à mater un
ça va
ferra pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]